leo je vous lis mon mec de la semaine ok
tant d'histoires pourquoi pas me faire
un mec mac et le mec mac et juste qui
déjà maquillé mais c'est ce son intérêt
dans ce genre d'histoire en reste que le
meilleur
les 90 de ce qui fait la beauté des
premiers moments et bien sûr du cul du
cul du cul oui et 7 chez lui non pas
vraiment ok ben vas-y qu'est ce que tu
proposes cette semaine à et mon talon ai
trop marre des auréoles sous les bras
non je pensais plutôt sommes-nous tout
des mots clés sur youporn joliot quoi
sur youporn blonde reder brune milf
traduisez merck ont un vrai baiser moi
donc c'est vrai que les mecs ont quand
même très organisé quand il s'agit de
ranger dans la barre de recherche
lila s'il savait le nombre de mecs qui
goutte de sueur en tapant bien en chair
sur le clavier je serais étonné ça
ferait du bien clémentine aussitôt
colocataires d'un lieu de culpabiliser
parce qu'il ce fameux pardon qu'il fait
ses petits comptes sur internet
eh ben on va lui montrer que tu est
mille fois plus bandante que la team qui
se trémoussent sur son 15 pouces et puis
moi si on a besoin de coller une
étiquette de cougar ou 2009 sur la tête
parce que j'essaie tridon quand les yeux
comme la colle
soyons le fantasme au delà du fantasme
parce que le fantasme il est là mais il
bouge pas mais nous nous on est vivants
tenant alors tout des mots clés sur
youporn d'accord mais vous avez intérêt
sur et